les cherry on va jouer dans un instant a
déroulé ses thériault vous laisser
gagner avant d'accueillir alban ivanov
exceptionnel et sabrina ouazani
l'arbitré magnifique frère vous nous
avez réclamé les jeux dans le hall ils
sont de retour le désir le déroulé c'est
gagner c'est très simple regardez moi je
suis comme ça aujourd'hui parce que
c'est la journée sans pantalon à 7 aux
comptes devant dépenses en organique
regardez regardez ce que c'est que la
vidéo la lorraine la vidéo regardez
c'est la garder
[Musique]
voilà voilà donc ça voilà donc mon
statut comme ça ça nous va très bien
cher et bien vu très très bien le jeu
soit belaid a un truc de fou quoi pénal
pose est impressionnant mais pourrait
non mais c'est vrai vous avez vous avez
le plus vous avez la peste ou ces fermes
la cuisse galbées français touché mais
je peux pas les images et on change les
taux sont ses services ben oui bah oui
je demande
il s'attendait au point mais ça fait m
je peux le cucul chef ce que vous voulez
gfr à g 20 qui feinte oui est ce que je
sais moi j'ai toujours dit que vous
aviez un très beau fils y ait de très
belles jamba merci ça fait plaisir qu'on
apprend des choses ans et j'ai dit oui
est ce que le jeu en rapport avec
l'épidémie de gastro en ce moment en
france oui bah oui épidémie de gastro
alors je vous donne un conseil et chérie
arrêtez de vouloir serrer les mains des
gens disent que c'est relou d'accord
j'en ai même qui vient te voir qui vote
serré la main si la ceni on s'est dit
bonjour convient à yannick janas et mon
butin mais ne sont pas canada ce
trottoir tout mais qui vous a demandé
votre la bcae mois grave
alors je vous le dis très bien alors
c'est un conseil gastronomique gaza ne
tira de gassion préféré la bise oui à la
poignée dans la longue ça suit avec la
main et pas avec la exactement et non
pas avec la bouche suit paul verlaine
les chéris attention c'est très sain on
va commencer donc vous allez devoir
tirer votre papier toilette a un qui est
terminée au rouleau après on le prendra
en plus un jour apple en plus qu'on a on
appartenait merci avez vous vécu cela
merci
c'est vraiment pas qui est très épais et
les tutos of gagner dès maintenant un an
de papier toilette doublé mais c'est
très simple et non c'est très normal oui
ça fait beaucoup merci
alors c'est très simple c'est très
simple et chérie alors je vous le dis il
faut faire il faut renvoyer sur twitter
voilà pour jouer avec nous je vous dis
un an de papier toilette et pas
n'importe lequel ce que je dis ça dit du
tout ce lot est le premier c'est le
premier pas et les toilettes du marché
sans tube au milieu de ces pratiques
écologiques d'accord mais chéri ok alors
c'est très simple attention il y aura
les quatre premiers qui seront qualifiés
d'accord je vous le dis à la fin le
grand gagnant désignera celui qui sera
comme ça pendant toute l'émission c'est
à dire sans pantalon est d'accord mais
attention c'est parti pour trois doigts
attention un papier déchiré et à papier
aller vite vite vite
les quatre premiers sont qualifiés
n'aura qu'à limoux père kevin kelly et
benali vous trichez pas été nominé qui
ont déménagé éliminé éliminé 7-6 faut
tirer
j'ai eu des bonnes gens michel qualifié
jules cluzel
[Musique]
elle aurait il avait qualifié moi
j'enlève on est éliminé mais quand même
on est tombé il ranime d'arriver à
l'ordre les 4 gilles isabelle jean
michel raymond les autres éliminés ok
merci
attention les quatre premiers s'il vous
plaît est ce qu'on voudrait changer
olive est habile j'ai fait revenir
chargées chargé pour la deuxième manche
de sa cheville va gagner non pas des
matelas de quatre premiers merci merci
alexandra je garde le bien alexandre qui
vient de se réveiller mon chéri ça on
devait merci c'est pas de ce côté mon
chéri c'est comme ça bon bah je pense
que c'est mieux comme ça
voilà merci monsieur l'heure du midi je
le fais sa magie je suis très content de
te revoir voulait faire partager je vous
racontais un truc qui m'est arrivé vous
allez halluciner de taser attention
maintenant ce sera les deux premiers
kadhafi attention les deux premiers
qualifiés est ce que vous êtes prêts à
temps
attendez cv l'attention à temps plein
oui en syrie
la finale ce sera jean michel et jean
michel et isabelle attention à bien ce
sont mes chéris ont la grande finale il
appelle face à jean mi j'aurais pas
miser sur sa non tachées vous pourrez
gagner des billets toilettes
c'est à papier toilette sans tube
attention c'est parti
jean me contre isa il c'est isaac et
challans c'est jean-michel c'est jean
michel gonzalez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vas desarollo on n'en joue pas que le
papillon wallon valeureux utiliser merci
je vous dise il est propre
donc laissez lui ont valu qu'il oui les
chéris jean michel c'est toi qui va
désigner qui va être sans pantalon
pendant toute l'émission qui choisis tu
avant que je lance au générique on peut
prendre une fille qui tu veux je veux
prendre
benjamin castadi allez c'est parti
courez vite allez vous mettre au vert
l'étude vital nous mettre en boîte vous
allez voir ya quelqu'un qui nous attend